[Music]
marvel studios shanxi and the legend of
the 10 rings introduces some of the
newest most dynamic artifacts in the
marvel cinematic universe the ten rings
so i'm getting the inside scoop from vfx
supervisor christopher townsend hey
chris hey how are you doing all right
chris let's get into it now what was the
process of reimagining the look and the
powers of the ten rings uh one of the
interesting aspects of obviously this
film with other ten rings and their
powers in the comics they're represented
as finger rings and we wanted to go more
onto almost bracelets and rings around
the wrist we started looking into the
idea of having each individual ring be
representative of a particular power
as it's represented in the comics but
again decided we didn't really want to
do that and we wanted to keep it a
little bit more simple and show them as
just a more unified sort of presence of
what these rings are doing and we
started going down this journey of not
really being about the rings themselves
that are powerful but rather it's the
energy that they emanate that was going
to be the power
right so once you have that look and
movement how do you then communicate
that with the performers on set do you
give them something that they can
actually physically wear
so there's a lot of development trying
to figure out exactly what we should
build as as the onset pieces for the
rings it was a real challenge trying to
figure out what should they look like
and should they be going small to large
and eventually we decided that they
would need to be changing and animating
so for the vast majority of the shots
that you'll see the rings even when
they're just rattling around on his
wrists they're actually fully computer
generated
the rings are so dynamic especially
because they emit a different color
dependent on who's wielding them what
was the process of choosing which
character would wield which color so
trying to find the correct colors for
shanxi when he uses the rings and for
when he uses the rings was kind of
tricky coming down to color specifically
we ended up with the golds for shangji
and sort of a purplish blue for when woo
as our sort of two key colors
so when we see that big final climactic
battle between changshi and wen wu we
really get to see how the ten rings emit
different powers when they're wielded in
different fighting styles could you
point out some of those subtle
differences so i think one of the
interesting things with the film is how
the rings are different for each
character in essence when woo is not
necessarily fundamentally evil but there
are sort of aggressive overtones to who
he is as a character and so the
characterization of those rings was an
extension of that and when shanxi
when he's using the rings there's almost
an aura of goodness about him so when
he's in a almost a tug of war moment
with his father we see when woohoo uses
the sort of lightning-based energy very
spiky and aggressive relative to
champions almost silk ribbons of glowing
energy and flowing and it's a much more
gentle serene power
this scene really has so many layers
because there's this intense action
paired with these really powerful
emotional moments what role does vfx
play in helping to create and support
those kinds of layers so we use a lot of
what we call previous pre-visualization
where we will try and figure or plan out
a particular scene so that we know
exactly where it's going to end up we
also in this case used a lot of stunt
biz so the stunt team would go away and
they would enact the entire sequence and
once you've figured out what the move is
you're then also at the same time
figuring out what the camera is doing
and how the camera reacts to the stunts
and how it reacts to the stunts with the
visual effects that are ultimately
placed on it once you've actually
finished photographing in principle
photography and you've got these
particular you know stunt fights you
know the sequences it's then our task to
start assembling it and putting it into
the scene
the world itself doesn't exist it's a
fully computer generated world for a lot
of this stuff particularly when you're
out on the what we call the mountain of
souls in front of the gate so we've
already planned it and we've prepped it
so that everyone knows exactly you know
what it's going to feel like but we
ultimately ended up replacing all of it
we have to track the camera and figure
out where the camera is in relation to
the actors and in relation to the world
that does exist in their the ground
playing all that kind of stuff and what
we're doing with the visual effects is
trying to enhance that and help further
that story arc and that characterization
it really is such an awesome ride what
do you hope that fans feel when they
walk away from that film i hope that
when the fans have watched the film that
they come away
thinking that not only they had a really
good ride that they've seen some
incredible fights but that ultimately
it's about relationships and it's about
love and family it's just got so much
going on and i think it's really
exciting to be working on a film that
has so many different
touch points that hopefully an audience
can get excited about
oh thank you so much chris and of course
everyone go see marvel studios chongqi
and the legend of the 10 rings in
theaters now
[Music]
[Music]
you